[Music]
do
[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
bleacher reports pre-game picks
the only show in the world where you the
people at home get to win free cash
prizes
by simply predicting the random [ __ ]
that occurs in the nba pregame
tonight we got the milwaukee bucks and
the brooklyn nets
and we got a lot of money to give away
so stay tuned
and let's get to these pics baby
how crazy is that wait is that a three
let's see that's a three that's a three
step curry wow my name is i told y'all
welcome to pregame picks
let's get it as always
welcome back to another episode of
pregame picks i am your host pierre aka
pee wee the plug
and i'm joined by my brother from
another
famous lois lois was cracking with you
i see you in a different job new music
out new music out go get it
new music out what up though y'all
where you at with it man i can't tell
you
you know i'm moving silence don't ever
ask me where i'm at when i'm online like
that boy
i'm in chicago all right you there you
go
bad boy in chicago i wasn't going to say
it but
let me show you i am vocal for actually
where you was at
undisclosed locations at all times but
what's cracking with you bro how you
feeling you ready to give away some
money
the plan today is to give away as much
money as we can
i want to give away it all let's do it
that's what i'm trying to do tonight all
right
they just got to bed with us they got to
go with us don't be against us today i'm
feeling lucky don't be
don't be against us today that's you hey
you take that advice too you don't don't
bet against what i say what i say is
gold today i'm telling you i'm on one
i'm feeling today i'm listening i'm
rolling
the day i'll listen to another light
skinned dude
would be a day in hell are you drunk boy
i'm listening to
likes the news exactly you listen
i bet drake had a lot of players for you
but anyway
the opening question we got for you and
everybody at home
so everybody at home make sure y'all
comment below is the play-in tournament
a good idea why
why not we heard lebron talking about
somebody needing to get fired
so i had to ask you how you feel about
it yeah brian is funny
yeah that's some new [ __ ] that's some
new [ __ ] man stop all that that
in but if you don't get in there you
just don't get in there
pause that play nbs ain't here bruh
i don't like what they're doing with
that hey but if steph if steph got to
play in [ __ ]
we need to play in see
[Applause]
i feel the same way all right i ain't
with the player either but i was
definitely going to ask you
how you felt about it for the warriors
but i'm joking
at home in the living room ain't no chat
ain't nobody saying
jesus ain't no second chances no
but listen the only problem i had with
what lebron said
was why he waited he in the seventh seed
to say it when it was late
i can't be on the camera when you say
some [ __ ] about when you say something
negative about bombs
i ain't saying nothing negative about uh
i'm just saying why he weighed today was
in the seventh seed
but um because cuz
you know how he is you know you you know
you know i do want to give a shout out
to uh
to my boy jonathan underscore s i'm in
the comments i see y'all make sure y'all
flood those comments
but jonathan underscore s says yes
it gives another team the opportunity to
get hot and upset plus more basketball
for us equals we win
he got me there mo basketball i like
more basketball
i like more basketball but more
opportunity this ain't no
but what you think this is what do you
think this is hey as long as we
and as long as we get more basketball
i'm fine with it
at the end of the day so guess what
jonathan is gonna get two hundred
dollars
we give it jonathan that's two hundred
dollars
yeah we like that last part we the
opportunity i feel you you grown ass man
you had all season to have more
opportunity
but more basketball for the people at
home the better so
jonathan underscore asked you win 200 we
starting to show off like that
so now for the next you digs everybody
be tuned in
be active in the comments because as you
can see we're giving away a lot
of money can we get that first prompt
going or
or are they are we still waiting for
them to hit the floor
hey yo i'm seeing so many milwaukee
different jerseys
fires what hey i like the blue ones i'm
not gonna lie i like the boom
that's where the yellow the look did you
see that yellow green patchy kind of one
the last one can we go back to the
yellow one because i ain't see it before
we introduce this next product
either the one before this was d rose
and then the one before that but it was
a d rose one then it was a yellow
okay
yeah but that shit's so ugly
you ain't got no doubt that [ __ ] that
[ __ ] so
you ain't got no taste [ __ ] you got a
[ __ ] plaid
got a plaid doo doo doo doo blue shirt
on
what are you talking about hey
the first the first prompt is it over
yet and then oh my [ __ ] that's why
you still got your mask on it's gonna be
around
and not be six feet apart so no it ain't
over
but the first thing we got is who will
make more shots
in the first 10 minutes of warm-up katie
or giannis
lost if you say the wrong answer i'm on
your ass like a diaper so
so please inform the people who gonna
make more shots in the first 10 minutes
of warm-up
hey hey i i say we have fun today i
think we have fun today let's go with gg
let's go with gg let's go who gg
i say we have fun today let's go hey
let's say gigi's gonna make more than kd
uh-uh no sir i hey i'm all for having
fun
but i ain't no no way no way
give me k.d i'm standing there okay i
like if you're going k.d i'm going gg
i'm i bet that so what what's me
if you had the crib vote with me with gg
i'm telling y'all i have a six sentence
oh hell no hell no put some sleeves on
and score him to the back and make him
put some sleeves on
right now he's cutting up i know he must
be right now
really tight right now i know he must
cut back to my man
cut back come back to no sleeves real
quick we'll get to the bucks and nets
coming to the court
we got plenty of time to see them come
to the court look but please go back to
no
just in case somebody roll her ankle he
game ready
at that point he said he needed to
understand that
you some kind of blake yeah
blake um blake mama blake mama my mama
auntie
so he like my second cousin tell
y'all how can you tell i ain't got no
type of red hair
i ain't got no type of red hair at all i
don't know something something about
y'all
you resemble each other you you got some
key in the jeff green
yeah you jeff green
and patrick beverly y'all around that
same family tree somewhere in the past
y'all
y'all jeans got intertwined y'all
looking
a little similar yeah
that's my boy though i'm riding with kd
i got kd making more shots in the first
10 minutes of pre-game
so don't try to say you know can katie
cause if he was you would have picked
him
where's ggs
that's why that's why we ain't starting
yet ain't no counter for kd yet because
we waiting for
giannis to come out so everybody at home
that ain't familiar
we wait until both teams are on the
court and both players are actively
getting shots out so nobody gets an
advantage
even though i hate when my guy that i
pick is out there first because that
means he usually exits the court first
well yeah so low low low slow key got an
advantage right now
i already had one all right because i
told you because i said it
but you never answered my question what
what's our personal bet uh
we gotta do something extreme i'm tired
of joining
we gotta do something hey what was i bet
last y'all remember we had a bed
we did who won what was the game we said
it was going to be put you it was going
to be jumping jacks whenever you see him
i said well you said you said i was
going to do jumping jacks whenever you
say
it wasn't just like jumping jack boom
you're going to say whenever you tell me
dude
right whenever you t yeah but did i win
it better did you win a bet
i i i definitely won hey gg and them out
starting to count
start to count yeah let's go
[Applause]
let's
i just want to take the time out to
remind everybody at home that may have
just tuned in maybe you're left for a
second
me and lois right now are watching
giannis and kd we're trying to figure
out who's going to make the most shots
in the first 10 minutes of warm-ups
i have kevin durant the slim reaper
and los lose for some damn reason
decided he wanted to pick giannis after
takumpo
hey fyi fyi fykd is doing
single jumpers right now and uh gg is in
in a layup line so i'm just letting
y'all know that that's why kd is going
up so quick
yeah boy look at gg handle
yeah he he handling that thing i ain't
gonna having that bro and i like them
shoes
whenever we can can we get a close-up
look at yana shoes they look mismatched
what's your favorite who your favorite
nike shoe who your favorite nike shoe
paul george
uh kd cat paul george okay
george okay literally mostly only nice
nice though i ain't gonna lie yeah i
like that
i like them hey everybody y'all let me
know who you are
who y'all favorite shoes is at home we
probably gonna get a lot of giannis
i i do think that paul george got the
best uh the best nike collection though
him or kyrie real
yeah more kind of gta gg shoes fire too
i got some fire ggs
hey and i know we talking about shoes
but i want you to keep keep a look at
that skull
single jumpers but with the kd doing
single jumpers gg in the layup line boy
damn
well he he he better he better start
controlling his team so he can catch up
because right now
i got my legs up i got my i'm chilling
i'm co i'm cool and i got
eleven two come on pull up come on kd
we need we need a slider rule if kd get
up 20
the bet is done we don't need to need to
waste no more than he's doing single
jumpers right now
gg is still in layup line you don't make
sense
hey he needs to start shooting his
jumper then
is that splash yep 13.
yes sir
kaylee really does i'm sorry y'all
seven game series right now bucks nets
who you got
who i got i want to have fun i'm going
with the books
oh my gosh hey hey it's hard at playing
i i i if hard and playing i'm with them
it's harder not playing no
no hard not playing tonight but if the
playoffs started i get i
guarantee hardin would play in this game
oh yeah if
if if hardin was playing on the playoffs
i'm with them
hardin really hard and really you know
the
pg on that team controlling the show he
is
he is now look this way you may be able
to come back because like i said
whenever my guy out there first
he tends to lead the court first so
kevin durant look like he going to take
a seat
a dog he just shot single jumpers
gigi just got out of them um or layup
lines
look at that okay if it may not be no
excuse for him not to tie this thing
up then we still got a 12 point lead
watch though look we still got a 12
point lead digit
good split cat watch it hey i watched he
called him through
he comes stepping we might hit up
shots down like he's supposed to we we
might have us
we might have us a little battle right
here go ahead you're actually rooting
for that
jumper look good as hell [ __ ] kd coming
back
he said that's too many he said uh no no
no i gotta help pee out
i know you ain't just missed that damn
shot katie come on
dude you shot it he shot up on the bench
okay like he's looking up at the screen
at the school he look at him at the
school
yeah hey yo count that [ __ ] man they got
gg jumper out
hey so yeah so look if you want if you
bought it with me with gg how much money
do you win
if you win 500 500
y'all better vote with me vote i'm
telling y'all change your vote vote with
me you got five minutes to change your
vote i'm telling you right now
500 bandols all this all the smart
intelligent individuals that we have
watching because 99.9 percent of them
are all
intelligent smart individuals they
picked me already hey
pop some of them comments on the screen
so lois can see pop some of them
i want to give some of my people
i want to give some of my people that uh
that that went with me
i want to get on some shout outs so can
i start seeing some some comments on the
screen if not i'll go to my phone and
check
katie loves one uh warming up jumpers he
going to cruise to an easy w
shout out to adam adam i hope you wanted
a 500 winners because you're so smart
adam
you're just so smart well i mean stop
making excuses
what excuses am i making though hey
hey shout out to atc atc
i'm gonna make
hydronium 26 kd such a pure jumper with
all due respect to giannis
all they all are just so intelligent yes
i guess we got a whole
just but look this is harvard fan base
this is not about katie you're always
taking a warm-up serious
katie all day shout out to jesse yeah
k.d look real serious right now
it's he didn't don't don't don't believe
that
you're about to do don't forget that
layout he's been sitting down
for four minutes and still got a six
point lead and production in my ear
you're telling me
honestly went cold he did he said he
came that's why i said
gg jumping like a damn hurt but here we
go okay
okay here we go here we go here we go
yeah i can't eat back out there come on
k dizzle
come on i told y'all we was gonna have a
game stupid
i told y'all come on i should have
bought it with me
five hundred dollars y'all don't y'all
man this [ __ ] gg man
this [ __ ] yeah katie
yeah kd get your stretch on get your
stretch on
get your stretch on gg back in the mix
get right back in the mix hey i do want
to give a shout out to katie and yannis
because this they are making this
interesting i ain't gonna lie
this is it's gonna come down to the
final it's gonna come down to the final
final second and i i'm happy with my
pick
i got all confidence in the world that
k.d gonna come through for me
while he's stretching yeah blowing them
hands giannis
i'm really i'm really pissed that gigi
missed all them damn easy
easy pull-ups right there now gigi stop
pulling up
okay good pull out jj okay okay
okay he's challenging himself i like it
i like it come on come on
come on
while we down to the last two minutes
and 30 seconds to figure out if katie or
giannis is going to win
um for the most shots in the first 10
minutes of warm-ups the second prompt
will be
will the brooklyn nets last shot be a
make or a miss
i'm gonna let i'm gonna let lois dwell
on that oh he already said mate you
saying mate
i don't know why i feel so confident
today about all my answers
i swear gg is crazy you're saying
for some for some reason i'm feeling
like it's a miss i hate which i i
i had a chance when i said it i told
y'all
but you're still losing relax you're
still losing it's about to be 18 18
right now y'all should have voted with
me
i pray we have voted for with me y'all
y'all about to be hey
with all due respect to the back-to-back
mvp and defensive player of the year
i hope he keeps shooting jumpers i hope
he gets trigger happy
this next will need to be a layup
because he know i'm trying to tie look
at kd
kd's so comfortable he like this ain't
[ __ ] i can lay on my back i ain't really
got no challenge
you know that ain't your game oh wow we
[Applause]
that's what i'm saying katie i mean atc
oh my gosh oh my gosh
richard you're about to be fired
i told
[Music]
they saying it's like the cavs and
warriors they saying i blew a 3-1 lead
but don't get too excited kd is gonna
get up in the last 40 seconds
[Applause]
[ __ ] this man laying on his damn stomach
10 seconds oh my gosh seven seconds to
victory i told y'all nobody gets three
four three two i ain't gonna say the
last one
if you're with me you just won five
goddamn oh
my gosh
you wrote it with me you just won 500.
listen
i want to look i want to look deeply
into the camera don't adjust me
i want to get deep into the camera i am
so sorry for everybody that rocked with
me
kd was the right pick as you all saw we
had a 10 to 12 point lead
he laid down and got comfortable that
that's not my fault
hold on say it again i'm recording you
now
i said i want to apologize for all the
people that came with me because we
should have won
but kd got too comfortable shout out to
the winners smiling you with that uh
paul johnson barry
west coast fan west west coast fan means
he's a buck fan he's from wisconsin
jamal dexter e and smiles
shout out to y'all for rocking with lost
y'all 500
richer make sure y'all go in that
bleacher report app and check your dms
at some point and sometime today
they will make sure that you get your
500 dollars
now loss are you staying with the mate
yeah i'm going to vegas i'm feeling so
lucky right now
i'm feeling hot see that's that that's
the difference between me and you
you get lucky i just do this [ __ ]
yeah and right now [ __ ] you're
doing the wrong [ __ ] you just lost
you just lost 500 to somebody you just
lost somebody 500
and they were going to use that for real
some food or something
but about to redeem myself with this one
because
the final shot of the nets warm-up
will be a miss
hey look i'll run it like [ __ ] you wrong
as hell
this is the final giveaway of the two
2020 nba season
the brooklyn nets final shots 21 season
the final shot uh for the brooklyn nets
will be missed
lois you saying mate are you saying hey
listen
listen listen i'm gonna make sure i'm
listening we got 29 seconds we got to
make sure
it's when the leaves the hands if you
leave their hand
that's the last person okay
how much 200 200
five people huh
so you you saying it's a make it's a
mate yo
three why is it it's a miss it's a miss
it's a miss it's a mess i told y'all
i told y'all it's a myth
i can't be wrong too many times i can't
be wrong too many times
i ain't new to this i'm true to this
show that replay who was there with them
yellow ass shoes on is that blake
tripping
oh bruce brown oh my god
the last was a mess i'm sorry y'all
if you if you bought it with me i'm
sorry
no if they walk if they work if they
voted with you don't be sorry because
they they silly ass they should have
listened to me
it's just that simple you ain't got to
be sad as hell
that's why
[Music]
hey boom shout out to atc25 he said he
always rock with me so he 200 dollars
richer
shout out abc just won ozzie morrell
shout out to uh ryan boyd habanero 24
kenny legend y'all got some crazy names
but i love all of y'all
it was a hell of a season um hopefully
i was able to get you all a lot of money
lost was able to get y'all some money we
gave away how much we gave away 900
times you were not able to give them a
lot of money you
[ __ ] made them lose like two thousand
dollars we two hundred dollars for a
comment
five people with 500 500 do the math i
can't do the math that fast y'all
shout out to all the fans we love y'all
lost you know you're a brother from
another my boy y'all go get that new
music
hey we we locked in for life my boy
everybody go for 42. yes sir
get in we got it here
[Music]
[Music]
uh